let's go next to our caller from the 702
area code caller from 702 who's there
where you're calling from I gave it as
Kara on bogus hey Tara what's going on
my first time calling I'm a new listener
I had a thought no one be aspirin no
Qingyun for progressives you think that
a mass exodus from cable and satellite
services would help well what would it
help me what I mean what would you and
Matt what's the what are you trying to
achieve by canceling cable and satellite
service I just got hit corporate media
in any way possible and if you hit
corporate media imagine that a bunch of
progressives do that so corporate media
loses a bunch of money because of people
canceling and it makes the remaining
audience more right-wing because it's
just the left that's canceling
subscriptions
then what would corporate media do in
response good question yeah I mean I'm
not asking it in any I'm asking it in a
serious way not rhetorically like I'm
wondering if you know five or ten
percent of progressives cancel corporate
media cable subscriptions whatever now a
much more conservative audience is left
what would they do I don't know I mean
they might say let's better appeal to
the right or let's try to get some of
those left wingers back I'm not sure
what image window
viewership but maybe grow people like
yourself in our podcast and you know
progressive voices on another platform
that's just what I was thinking because
I'm personally going to cancel my
satellite because I can't seem to find
news anymore interesting well listen I
mean what you have to remember is a lot
of people get cable TV and Internet from
the same provider so and oftentimes what
you pay for internet goes up when you
don't have one of these so-called
bundles so instead of paying 80 bucks
for cable and TV you might cancel TV and
end up paying 60 just for internet cable
and internet rather so you know it's
this is what happens when you have a no
legally or monopoly you really don't
have many choice
Oh their coins thank you David
alright thank you for the call
appreciate it